it's such a strange thing that your mom
is a school teacher but when you tell
her you're dropping out of school to
join scream i'm like boy what an unusual
mother and how supportive but your dad
on the other hand i kind of get him he's
saying to you son
you're going to be a loser in life you
need to finish high school
and you need to start thinking
realistically about the future
we were very conflicted you know i mean
my father was a classically trained
flautist he was a musician with perfect
pitch and he had the ear and he had the
musical mind i'm sure that he had his
own weird sense of synesthesia where he
could see music like stuff like that um
i i actually wrote i wrote an article an
article about this for the atlantic and
it basically says like how far does the
apple fall from the tree in my case it
rolled all the way down the [ __ ] hill
you know and when i talk about
our
similarities and i'm i'm who i am
because of this person and so yeah we
had a really strained relationship until
i was maybe in my 20s and then we became
friends you know and then we get like as
a as i became a man
we like we sort of saw each other on
this new level and it's great you know
one of the reasons why my mother
was okay with me dropping out of high
school is because she was a high school
english teacher and so she knew that no
children no two children learn the same
and sometimes it's not the kid that
feels the school it's the school that
fills the kid and she didn't think i was
a complete idiot you know she just knew
that i wasn't gonna make it under the
fluorescent lights of this of this
public school thing so when i said i
gotta go i gotta go play music she said
you better be good that's it and my
father on the other hand was like
good luck i mean he took i think he was
saving money for me to go to college and
then the next time i saw him he had this
like forest green
plymouth volare like he got like a brand
new car
your dad said good luck and stay off the
drugs and that was it and you didn't
talk to him for a little he was
basically saying you're no longer my son
i'll tell you once i did become
successful that was the beginning of
this new relationship because when
first of all when nirvana became popular
one of the first things he said is
you know this isn't going to last right
like you got maybe a good year maybe two
years in this in this game and then
that's it and i agreed with him i was
like yeah of course he's like so every
check you make you got to treat it like
it's the last one you're ever going to
make did you ever jam with your father
in other words did he ever did you ever
take out a guitar and play and he played
the flute don't you think that would
have been beautiful the reason why he
stopped playing music
was because he couldn't
support himself or a family playing the
[ __ ] flute
and he thought why play an instrument
unless you can play it four hours a day
right he used to say to me he would say
don't call yourself a musician just
because you play an instrument like to
him it was this like this life devotion
if you're gonna play the flute you're
gonna [ __ ] play the flute all day
long you're not just gonna whip it out
like once a weekend or something like
that so he just stopped he put it away
and i've i only heard him do it once
and then you know there were times where
like i would send him a foo fighters
record and he would sit in his aim's
chair with like a scotch and a pipe and
a conductor's baton and like sit there
and conduct along with the music
yeah it was a trip man